wenn du einen pflanzplan für deinen
gemüsegarten erstellen möchtest dann
kann das schirmherr schön kompliziert er
muss ja die fruchtfolgen alle beachten
du brauchst passende mischkultur partner
für alle gemüse die lu anbauen möchtest
du musst vor haupt und nach kulturen aus
flügeln und dann wäre eine gestaffelte
ernte auch noch ganz sinnvoll wie man
das alles unter einen hut kriegt das
kann einen schon manchmal überfordern
deswegen möchte ich dir mit diesem video
durch den planungs dschungel helfen und
ihr zeigen was wirklich wichtig ist wenn
du deinen pflanzplan erstellten ja jetzt
wo es langsam winter wird wir hatten
jetzt gestern schon den ersten schnee
auch wenn ich nur ein paar flöckchen
waren aber immerhin ist auch die
perfekte zeit um sich mal wieder ein
bisschen mit dem thema planung zu
beschäftigen für nächstes jahr zu planen
bis hin zu träumen ich mache das immer
super super gerne ich konnte mich auf
meinem sofa ein habe ich jemanden gar
ein tagebuch wo ich auch immer meine
ganzen anbaupläne rein schreibe und dann
setze ich mich einfach einmal im winter
hinnehmen da wirklich ein paar tage für
zeit und überlege mir wie der garten
nächstes jahr aussehen soll was ich an
bauen möchte gibt es neue gemüse dich
ausprobieren will
was möchte ich anders machen das hat
dieses jahr gut geklappt das hat nicht
so gut geklappt auf welchen beten möchte
ich was anbauen und da möchte ich euch
einladen das mit mir zusammen zu machen
in den nächsten wochen werde ich auch
noch mehr
detailliertere videos zum thema
anbauplanung posten also abonniert den
kanal und drückt die glocke damit ihr
die nächsten videos nicht verpasst und
dann können wir alle zusammen über
unseren an bauplänen grübeln der erste
schritt ist finde ich auch gleich der
schönste nämlich dass du dir überlegt
welche gemüse du nächstes jahr überhaupt
anbauen möchte ist also da kannst du dir
zum beispiel überlegen was besonders gut
schmeckt das ist natürlich das
allerwichtigste dass man vor allem die
sachen an bord die ratz fatz aufgegessen
sind auf die sich die ganze familie
freut und auch die nachbarn freuen oder
die freunde die man somit versorgt dann
kannst du dir überlegen welche gemüse im
supermarkt oder im bioladen besonders
teuer sind da lohnt es sich dann
natürlich wenn man die selbe anbaut oder
abgefahrene alte gemüsesorten die
gar nicht mehr kennt die man unbedingt
ausprobieren will wie zb haarwurzel oder
die saatgut kataloge sind ja
mittlerweile auch voll von sachen die ja
die einfach spaß machen beim
experimentieren da bin ich auch in
meinen ganz großer freund dann wenn ich
mir die saatgut kataloge durch blättere
dann will ich am liebsten alles
ausprobieren was darunter ist wieder auf
klopft ist also da gibt es ja ganz viele
optionen und da mache ich mir immer am
anfang des jahres erst mal eine liste
mit allen gemüsen die ich in meinem
garten unterbringen möchte im nächsten
jahr was sind denn so eure
lieblingsgemüse die er jedes jahr an
bord und was sind die kandidaten die ihr
nächstes jahr unbedingt mal ausprobieren
wollte ihr vielleicht noch nie an gebaut
habt ich finde mich auf jeden fall
richtig freuen da mit euch unten in den
kommentaren ein bisschen zu plaudern
also lasst mir gerne einen kommentar da
wenn du dir die liste erstellt hast dann
kommen wir zu schritt nummer zwei das
ist die gemüse kumpel bude
da wollen wir nämlich die passenden
mischkultur partner für alle gemüse
herausfinden ich bin großer fan von
mischkultur das gibt ganz viele positive
effekte die mischkultur hat wenn du
nicht weisst was das ist das bedeutet
einfach dass du statt einer fläche die
du nur mit einem gemüse gepflanzt
unterschiedliche gemüse nebeneinander
pflanzt die sich unterschiedlich auf
unterschiedliche art und weise
unterstützen können das kann einmal sein
dass sie ganz physikalisch einfach nur
eine rankhilfe für andere gemüse sind
zum beispiel kann man sehr gut mais
anbauen und da stangen boden dran hoch
wachsen lassen die dann sozusagen den
mais als lange nutzen das wäre eine
tolle mischkultur es gibt aber auch so
tolle mischkulturen wie die mühle und
die zwiebel die sich gegenseitig
schädlinge vom leib halten das ist
natürlich super cool
manche gemüse nutzen einfach den platz
sehr gut untereinander aus da gibt es
ganz unterschiedliche sachen
wieso es sinnvoll sein kann gemüse
nebeneinander anzubauen und da habe ich
mir selber eine tabelle erstellt die
kann ich auch noch mal hier unter dem
video verlinken wo ich ganz viele
sinnvolle und wirksame mischkultur
partnerschaften aufgelistet habe und da
kombiniere ich dann erstmal die gemüse
die ich anbauen möchte so dass ich weiß
wer mit wem auf welchem gebiet wachsen
will
ich werde auch nächste woche glaube ich
ein video zur mischkultur posten wo ich
noch mal genau erklären was so unsere
kombinationen sind sobald das online ist
werde ich das ich glaube hier oben ein
blenden aber ihr wisst ich bin neu auf
youtube ich vielleicht ist es auch hier
ihr werdet es beim sehen wenn es live
ist wenn dann alle gemüse verkuppelt
sind kommen schritt nummer drei und das
ist die fruchtfolge erstellen das ist
ein thema das auch so ausführlich ist
dass sich dazu auch ein eigenes video
drehen werde aber mal gut erklärt die
fruchtfolge ist deswegen so wichtig weil
es schädlinge und krankheiten gibt die
relativ hartnäckig sind und die auf den
beeten überwintern und wenn du dann
jedes jahr das gleiche gemüse auf ein
und demselben bild anbaus dann triffst
du den krankheiten und schädlingen
natürlich genau das auf was sie essen
oder haben wollen dann viren verbreiten
sich krankheiten und schädlinge
natürlich umso schneller in deinem
garten deswegen ist es sinnvoll wenn du
die aus hunger ist die krankheiten und
die schädlinge und denen eben nicht dass
auftischt was sie haben wollen weil
viele schädlinge und krankheiten sind
genau auf eine pflanze spezialisiert
oder auf eine pflanzenfamilie und
deswegen ist es ganz ganz sinnvoll die
pflanzen familien je nachdem wie
hartnäckig die schädlinge und die
krankheiten sind die es auf diese
familie abgesehen haben erst nach
soundsoviel jahren wieder auf dem selben
bett anzubauen sollte jetzt kompliziert
an ist es eigentlich überhaupt nicht ich
werde euch das alles noch mal ganz genau
erklären sodass ihr wirklich kein
problem hat eine fruchtfolge zu
erstellen
ein anderer punkt sind nährstoffe also
manche gummi so wollen ja mehr dünger
oder mehr nährstoffe als andere und dann
ist es sehr sinnvoll wenn man auf allen
beta ist stark zähler an baut dann
mittel cera und dann schwach zähler das
wäre die einfachste form wie meine
fruchtfolge gestalten kann weil sie ja
auch erst stark serie damit sie ihre und
dann schwarz auf einem beet angebaut
werden und so hat man dann ja schon
logischerweise eine route pause
dazwischen gehabt bevor die nächsten
stark zähler wieder daran gebaut werden
aber man kann das eben noch ein bisschen
raffinierter gestalten und ein bisschen
mehr auf die pflanzenfamilien achten und
das werde ich euch noch mal genau in dem
video zeigen wenn man wirklich alles
beachten will bei der anbauplanung dann
ist das schon ganz schön kompliziert
also ich bin da auch immer im hin und
her posen und grübeln und knoop
deswegen habe ich für alle von euch die
darauf keine lust haben oder die einfach
ein bisschen inspiration brauchen wie so
ein anbau plan aussehen kann ein plan
erstellt ihr euch gerne herunterladen
könnt der link ist hier unter dem video
in der video beschreibung den könnt ihr
euch gerne auch an eure eigenen
bedürfnisse anpassen also da habe ich
mit dazu geschrieben wie ihr den
anpassen könnt wenn ihr zum beispiel
andere gemüse anbauen möchte als ich
davor gesehen habe einfach als
hilfestellung oder ihr könnt das
komplett eins zu eins in ihrem garten
umsetzen und habe dann eben einen anbau
klären wer alles berücksichtigt und der
den garten auch so ein teil das ihn
wirklich optimal nutzen könnte kommen
wir zu schritt nummer vier das ist die
gestaffelte ernte das sehe ich bei
gemüsegarten anfänger ganz oft ist sie
nur im frühling einmal alle gemüse
aussehen und danach nicht mehr aber wenn
man zum beispiel salat oder möhren oder
alle schnell wachsenden gemüse am
laufenden band ernten möchte dann muss
man auch regelmäßig aus wenn ich selbst
zum beispiel meine hören alle vier
wochen neu aus so dass wir das ganze
jahr über frische möhren aus dem garten
essen könnten genauso mache ich das mit
salat mit einigen anderen gemüsen und da
gilt es dann eben dass man
unterschiedliche auszeit punkte festlegt
da kannst du dir auch mal diese art
tütchen anschauen da steht nämlich oft
mit dabei wie lange es braucht bis das
gemüse erntereif ist und daran kannst du
dich dann orientieren wenn du planst
welche sätze du wann in welchem boot aus
sehen möchtest damit du wirklich das
ganze jahr über aus deinem garten ernten
kannst und nicht so eine große ernte
schwämme hast wo du dann alles zu viel
hass und die alle schon zu den ohren
raus kommt und danach ein paar wochen
später musste das ganze wieder im
supermarkt einkaufen so war das nämlich
bei uns als ich angefangen habe zu
gärtnern als ich das eben noch nicht
herausgefunden hatte wie das
funktioniert mit der gestaffelten aust
und der gestaffelten ernte also das ist
auch ganz ganz wichtig und dann schritt
nummer 5 sind die lückenbüßer also wenn
du dann auf deinem an bauplan sie ist
das irgendwo noch lücken sind das allen
bis juni leer steht dann kannst du da
natürlich irgend ein schnell wachsendes
gemüse noch vorschieben so dass deine
beete dann wirklich das ganze jahr über
optimal genutzt sind und wenn du das als
beachtet hast dann hast du wirklich
einen sehr sehr guten an bauplan
erstellt der durch durch die ganze
garten saison führt der dafür sorgt dass
du das ganze jahr über aus seinem garten
ernten kannst dass du die gemüseernte
die du auch möglich gerne ist und dann
gibt es nur noch einen schritt den du
machen sollte ist das empfehle ich
wirklich jedem von euch weil es mir so
unglaublich weiterhilft dass du dir die
aussaat termine die duh festgelegt hast
also zum vorziehen
zum sehen uns zum pflanzen in deinen
kalender schreibt damit du das dann auch
wirklich ein herz und nicht vergisst
weil ein anbau plan an dem man sich dann
den ganzen rest der saison über
überhaupt nicht hält der bringt
natürlich nichts das bringt nur was wenn
du das dann auch so in deinem garten
umsetzt er was ist denn so euer größtes
problem bei der anbauplanung das würde
mich jetzt noch interessieren dann kann
ich dann nämlich vielleicht in den
nächsten videos drauf eingehen und
wirklich die videos machen die euch auch
weiterhelfen ansonsten freue ich mich
auf die nächsten videos danke für das
ganze liebe feedback jetzt auch das
erste youtube-video es war wirklich so
so so schön eure ganzen kommentare zu
lesen ich habe mich so gefreut also ich
freue mich über jeden der abonniert auch
wenn ihr jetzt an eurem garten plant
sitzt wirklich abonniert den kanal damit
ihr die nächsten videos mitbekommt ich
freue mich total
ja dieses abenteuer jetzt mit euch zu
bestreiten und jetzt hier auch per video
für euch dazu sein dankeschön ihr seid
echt die besten